[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to an installment of harry
potter theory
in today's video we're going to be
discussing albus dumbledore's brother
aberforth dumbledore and his supposed
obsession
with goats aberforth dumbledore was a
british half-blood wizard
the older brother of ariana dumbledore
the younger brother of hogwarts
headmaster
albus dumbledore and the son of kendra
and percival dumbledore aberforth had a
poor relationship with his brother as
they were both involved in the three-way
jewel
involving grindelwald that led to the
death of their sister ariana
when ariana died it basically ended
their relationship
as aberforth blamed albus for her death
even though albus and aberforth were
brothers
and fairly close in age they were always
very different
they were not to like aberforth was
never bookish and
unlike albus preferred to settle
arguments by dueling
rather than through reasoned discussion
in fairness to aberforth
it must be admitted that living in albus
shadow could not have been an altogether
comfortable experience
the two parted ways in the year 1900
when albus was 19 and aberforth was 16.
aberforth later became the barman and
the hog set in in hogsmeade village
and though the brothers had a poor
relationship aberforth did later join
the order of the phoenix
during the first wizarding war in an
effort to help combat voldemort
though aberforth was quite a powerful
wizard he was a dumbledore after all
he preferred to live a quiet life he
enjoyed his job as a barman
and also kept farm animals most notably
goats
aberforth is presented by rolling in a
bit of an interesting light
perhaps to provide a bit of comic relief
as in the goblet of fire it's mentioned
briefly
that aberforth has a bit of an unusual
relationship with his goats
in fact he was even prosecuted for the
supposed things that he did with goats
my own brother aberforth was prosecuted
for practicing inappropriate charms on a
goat
it was all over the papers but did
aberforth hide
no he did not he held his head high and
went about his business as usual
of course i'm not entirely sure he can
read so that may not have been bravery
dumbledore also briefly mentions his
brother's unhealthy obsession with goats
in his notes in his copy of tales of
beedle the bard
i heard it first from my mother and it
soon became the tale i requested more
often than any other at bedtime
this frequently led to arguments with my
younger brother aberforth
whose favorite story was grumble the
grubby goat so
given that he was prosecuted what on
earth did aberforth possibly do
with goats this is a very unusual part
of the books and it really leaves things
wide open
to reader interpretation every reference
to aberforth
seems to mention goats his obsession
with them how he would play with them
and how he would go to feed them with
his sister so what did he do with them
that got him prosecuted
in an interview jk rowling addresses
this in the goblet of fire dumbledore
said his brother was prosecuted for
practicing inappropriate charms on a
goat
what with the inappropriate charms he
was practicing on that goat
i think that he was trying to make a
goat that was easy to keep clean
curly horns that's a joke that works on
a couple of levels
i really like aberforth and his goats
but you know i before having this
strange fondness for goats
if you've read book seven came in really
useful to harry later on
because a goat a stag you know if you're
a stupid death eater what's the
difference
so that is my answer to you rowling was
asked a similar question
in a fan letter why is one brother in
love with goats
this question made me raw with laughter
aberforth's goat fetish is a running
joke that kept me amused
i don't think he's really in love with
them but it's a good pretext for humor
here's what i think aberforth already
liked goats as a kid
fair enough they are interesting animals
however
what really cemented his love for goats
and what perpetuated his fondness for
goats with the fond childhood memories
that he had associated with them
it's well known that aberforth would
feed the ghosts with his sister ariana
this is the sister that he lost and when
they went to feed goats together
it was a simpler time when the family
was much more put together however
i think that this joke involving amber
forth and goats
is often perceived in a more
inappropriate context
i'm not going to spell this out for you
i'm sure you can figure it out for
yourself
however i like to look at it much more
innocently and i think that apple forth
was just a really odd guy with a strong
love for goats
and that's it for this video what do you
guys think aberforth did with goats
let's keep it pg until next time it does
not do to dwell on goats
and forget to live
[Music]